Speaker 1: All right. Let's briefly discuss
the growing, very explosive civil war within
the Republican Party. This is already a fight
for the 2024 Republican nomination. It is Trump
versus DeSantis. Both are in glass houses
and throwing many, many, many stones. Let's
start with Trump on DeSantis and then we will
look at DeSantis on Trump. On the Trump side,
Donald Trump is flipping out and recently called
Ron DeSantis fat, phony and whiny, which sounds
extraordinarily like projection. Let's discuss
it. Maggie Haberman has a new book coming out
and she wrote an article about her interviews for
the book for The Atlantic. Now I know it. Listen,
it's always the same routine. All of these folks,
they have all the good stuff and they hold it for
their books in order to sell books. It's what it
is. Doesn't mean that any of it is untrue. They
all do it. And Bolton did it. They all did it.
We talk about it. Is it immoral? To some degree,
yeah, maybe. I mean, here these are not claims
about national security implications, but we all
know that they do this. In the article in The
Atlantic three Conversations with Donald Trump,
there is a section about Ron DeSantis and Maggie
Haberman writes, I brought up another potential
future primary rival by mentioning that he had
been compared to New Jersey's feisty governor,
Chris Christie, before the two men faced off in
the 2016 primary. Trump replied, I was compared
to him. Why? I didn't know I had that big of a
weight problem. A small smirk followed. Then he's
an opportunist. I heard that Trump was describing
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis in similar terms,
calling him fat, phony and whiny while claiming
credit for making his candidacy in 2018.
What is with Trump and calling everyone fat?
Bill Barr recently called him fat. Chris
Christie recently posted of a picture of a guy at
a buffet. It's still not even clear to me whether
it was Chris Christie or not. It looks like Chris
Christie, but I don't know if it was and now Ron
DeSantis. And the projection is truly incredible.
And I think it goes to Trump's insecurities. Trump
is obese. Trump is obese. Trump claims to be 63
to 39. He's not six three and he weighs more than
239. And according to BMI, which is not a perfect
measure, but I think it's more or less right with
Trump. Trump is obese. Trump is a total phony,
he says. DeSantis is a phony. Trump developed a
fake persona to run as a Republican. Trump was
for abortion access for 68 years of his life,
and then he decided he's going to run for
president. And he said, No, no, no. I'm very,
very pro-life, as he describes it. And the story
he came up with is, you know, I met a woman
and I met the woman's kid. And the woman told
me I once thought about getting an abortion,
but now I have this great kid. And Trump said,
Wow, I liked the kid so much, I became against
abortion. Come on, guys. Trump's claims to be
religious. He's a complete and total phony,
which he accuses Ron DeSantis of being. And
I've never seen a bigger winner than Donald
Trump. I cannot think of in the political
world, bigger whiners than the Trump family.
We're the most poorly treated people ever.
I was the best president. And everyone says
mean things. They're all going after me.
They're mean, all this different stuff. And
what we are starting to see here with Trump and
DeSantis, as you're going to see in a moment,
is that narcissism is colliding with more
narcissism and you can get some really interesting
results. And we may indeed have that in the 2024
Republican primary if both of these guys run. Now,
the numbers in the 24 primary in the betting
markets have completely reversed in Ron DeSantis
favor. And I'm going to get to that in a moment.
But now that we've covered the Trump on descent
as part of the Republican Civil War. Let's go
to the DeSantis on Trump part of the Civil War.